the internet started out with a vision
of anyone can get a computer anyone can
go online and anyone can communicate
directly with anyone else but now that
hasn't gone away really I mean even or
is it or you said I've gone away okay
but what has happened is that the power
and the profits have gone to the very
few with the new internet that we're
building we are changing the rules once
again at the 2017 consensus conference
an eclectic group including
technologists bankers and libertarians
assembled in New York City to discuss
blockchain technology it's a relatively
new branch of computer science that some
claim will eliminate the need for
middlemen in many sectors giving rise to
a vast new peer-to-peer economy one of
the most ambitious companies in this
space is block stack which is attempting
to use blockchain technology to rebuild
the internet without intermediaries the
goal according to co-founders Moonee
Valley and Ryan Shay is to put
individual users back in control of the
web thus reducing the power of both
large companies and governments Google
has the same don't be evil
maybe a company shouldn't be powerful
enough that they're sitting there
thinking should I be evil or not
what does blocks that do and why is it
needed
so I think you should think of blocks AK
as a new internet almost like a second
internet or a parallel Internet to the
traditional system that we already have
and so it is it gives you the full stack
it gives you the entire Internet
infrastructure that you need like right
from like downloading a browser do you
type in like a domain name and how it's
resolved and how the data is presented
but it's designed in a very different
way from the traditional technology I
mean the traditional dredge is like 30
years old there are lots of like
security problems or reliability
problems in the core design and what we
did is that we basically did a complete
clean slate design using watching
technologies yeah I mean the internet
was designed to be decentralized right
it was it actually started out that way
and there's been a consolidation at the
end of the day you have to rely upon
Facebook or Google in order to access
the what is bad about that because
doesn't that mean that they are getting
a sense of who you are and what kinds of
stuffs you like any central repository
of data on like millions of people is
basically like a honeypot
it will get hat or the NSA or some other
government agency or some other country
would try to get access to that data the
fact that is available means that it can
be used and negatively as well
these honey pots Ali says are the data
centers maintained by these Internet
giants which are where most online
information is now stored so how does
block stack propose to alter cloud
computing which has brought enormous
efficiencies to the tech sector Ali and
Shea say they've worked out a way to
turn these facilities into the
equivalent of storage lockers where
individual users are the only ones who
hold the keys to their own data if
you're a dropbox engineer you can
actually go through all of my files
today but the way block stack works when
I use Dropbox again the same service but
through block stacking the there
engineers have no visibility into the
encrypted blobs of data that is actually
being stored there it doesn't matter if
it's provided by Dropbox or Google or
Amazon they're being reduced to these
like dumb hard drives that just stored
encrypted data the theoretical
challenges in building this new internet
architecture were the subject of ollies
Princeton PhD dissertation which he
successfully defended last month and it
was here on the Princeton campus that
alley at Shea met in 2013 and decided to
start a company together now block SEC
has raised close to five million dollars
in venture capital it has seven
employees and the development team is
expected to double in the next few
months as it builds the foundation for
this new internet none of this would be
possible if it weren't for the invention
of Bitcoin which was introduced to the
world in a 2008 paper written by a
pseudonymous developer it also described
a new type of distributed ledger for
keeping track of who owns what Bitcoin
called a blockchain block stack is part
of an entire industry that's now emerged
which is all about integrating the
blockchain into everything from real
estate markets to driverless car
technology what is the block trick one
way to think about it is a white pages
that the community maintains together
and anyone can actually add to it and
anyone can publish and distribute it one
important part about this white page is
that no one actually controls it
there's no intermediary I can send
something directly to you or to you I
don't have to drop it off at a post
office box and then the guy will be like
okay this goes over here you can walk
right over to the address
and put the envelope in the person's
mailbox how does block snack work like
that so in this case block stack gives
you your own secure mailbox where you
can actually store all of your data so
it's important that you have this open
public resource which is this white
pages that we all collectively maintain
to help us find each other safe so we
can put help put things in each other
safe and only you have control over your
own property your on address your safe
your mailbox and only I had control over
mine
Aly and Shay's say that these shared
digital white pages are what make
possible a fundamental reordering of the
internet structure today's web is
dominated by a handful of applications
owned by private companies that keep
track of our data identities and
contacts the only part of the internet
that's currently open and decentralized
are the programs we use to connect to
these walled gardens which are called
protocols but now that line is being
redrawn because many of the Internet's
essential functions no longer need to be
handled by a centralized entity
thanks to blockchain technology that
leaves applications like Twitter and
Facebook playing a far more limited role
it's almost like Twitter would be like a
radio like an old-style radio where you
turn it on you can you can push your
stuff through it but when you turn it
off they don't have a list or data of
everything that's a really good example
if you think of Twitter as like a radio
then you can go to any provider and buy
a radio set that you like using and just
use that for connecting to the same
network right so by doing the separation
of like what is the app that you're
using and the data is actually separate
right and you can actually switch these
apps you can let's say some other
competitor comes around and they're like
why don't you use my app then the users
get more choice and like whatever
software they use to actually produce
the Khan whywould Twitter be interested
in going along with this at all the way
that this can change the way that actual
decentralization can come about and a
very competitive market right real free
market economics the way that real free
market economics can emerge instead of
monopolies is with business models that
allow these small groups to
bootstrapped networks and to get user
adoption and to get paid and to be able
to actually sustain themselves so that
they can grow right so what we're doing
with block stack is we are enabling
small open source groups to actually
grow and compete with the large players
this new internet will undermine
government's ability to access users
personal data without permission the
Snowden leaks revealed that the NSA was
strong-arming Internet companies into
letting them read the digital files of
users by migrating all online
information into these encrypted storage
lockers block stack would make math data
collection impossible it seems to me
that that's an open invitation for the
government to say no [ __ ] way
we're not saying that there shouldn't be
a role for government to be able to
knock on someone's door and and asked us
for the data there we don't we do not
believe that there isn't a role for that
but in the traditional world in the
world before the internet the way that
that would work is individuals would get
surveilled one at a time you would have
a subpoena that you have to get from a
court and then you could use that to
actually go after an individual right
yeah that is that's the model that we've
worked with so for such a long time and
it's worked very well right we've now
entered a world where everyone could be
can be surveilled simultaneously for no
call almost no call additional cost
no marginal cost right so we have this
dragnet surveillance where billions of
people are getting surveilled at the
same time and it's just being plowed
into these massive massive buildings
right with data on everyone at every
single conversation on every single
intimate so I why as a user I would I
don't want that and as a company I see
an opportunity to say hey we're going to
pull your data out of that and it's
going to be in this secret you know
cubby hole that the only way the feds
are at whoever I mean or a corporation
could get to it is by coming to your
door and asking for it but then why
would the why would the government allow
something like that so I basically look
at this as like mathematics
we can just wait it out and somebody
else would do it but this is a world
where I don't see any possibility where
you can actually like ban encryption
governments would actually just need to
learn to be smarter so I mean really
what what you're saying is that the
encryption will always be ahead and that
the government will have to switch its
model from a dragnet surveillance to now
we're going to have to only go after
people who we have a suspicion it's not
like a software problem think of
encryption as like almost like a
physical content that you cannot deny
physics you cannot deny geomatics
encryption exists kind of like in a
similar way and we will have to learn to
live in a world where it exists lodges
have solve a very key problem and which
can be used for build the rest of the
internet stack by blocking at the
consensus conference block SEC released
an early version of its decentralized
web browser and the company held a
special session for developers to answer
questions and encourage them to start
building applications on this new
platform assuming that people move
towards this model how will it affect
the distribution of small medium and
large companies and in a given area web
service whenever there's a rule change
you see a few players emerge that
quickly are able to understand and play
the rules kind of those better than
anyone else and they that's when they
gain enormous amount of market share
right you see the internet did this new
companies were born and some existing
companies had started to wane a little
bit if you can change the rules if you
can allow for new business models to
emerge if you can allow for open
protocols and open source software to be
monetized if you can create a system
where companies can compete on a level
playing field and consumers can move
from provider to provider then that rule
change can allow for a new wave of
companies to emerge and I do believe
that this will create a much larger
economy and a lot more prosperity for
everyone
it will help consumers it will help
business owners it'll help a lot more
people to create sustainable businesses
[Music]
you